Legg in the Royal Wedding and Prince
Harry and Megan Markel's big day just
three days until they say I do if you
can believe it there's just so much
going on and I mean personally what I
kind of love about it I mean obviously
we don't wish anyone poorly but the
family drama makes this so relatable I
know right you've never seen it play out
like this not at William and Kate's
wedding I'll tell you that but like I
mention you guys we have everything you
need to know and the latest developments
let's give you a quick recap though on
what's been going on this week it all
started on Monday
you know Megan's father told TMZ that he
was pulling out of the Royal Wedding
because he had a heart attack a week ago
and also he didn't want to embarrass
Megan and the royal family following a
story that basically broke where he
staged paparazzi photos Yeah right what
a scandal that was it really was now so
so much has changed already since then a
source told et at the time that Megan
was quote devastated when she heard that
her father was not planning on coming to
the wedding anymore and she did reach
out to him in the 11th hour now on
Tuesday Thomas had reportedly changed
his mind and was planning on trying to
attend the wedding and walk his daughter
down the aisle but he told TMZ that he's
having heart surgery today that's
Wednesday which would presumably keep
him from getting to London by Saturday a
source also tells ET that Megan and
Harry are doing everything just to focus
on their love for each other during this
time hour sorts adds that Harry is quote
very protective of Megan and is hurt and
angered by all the attention and the way
that her family is being portrayed in
the media can you blame him I mean for
years as a kid he saw his mother
Princess Diana deal with aggressive
photographers up until the time she died
you know so I can only imagine how he's
feeling right now I've got to he has a
lot he wants to say but is trying to
keep it together for the sake of Megan
and her family and of course to keep
this special moment sacred absolutely
another source tells ET that quote Megan
and Harry have mixed emotions right now
between their concern for Megan's dad
and the exciting start of their life
together that's what I feel for them
because three days until they're
supposed to walk down that aisle all of
this is playing out in front of the
media so I can only imagine you know
that she has a huge support system
around her in fact we've learned that
she has the support in to form
one of course her mother Doria who
traveled from Los Angeles to be with her
in London and also her best friend
Jessica Mulrooney who we spotted at
Heathrow Airport this morning with her
family so she's surrounded by a lot of
love and that's all you can do right at
this point I think it's a lot of drama
but it's a lot of happiness too it's a
big wedding it's a big wedding so
hopefully they're how keeping her calm
and she's sipping on a little champagne
relaxing a little bit but as we mention
you know for Harry this really does
opened a wound having to you know
obviously having to see his mother deal
with paparazzi over the years I wonder
what she would be thinking about all
this if she was here absolutely right
well you know you guys obviously we have
learned of that Megan and Harry do plan
to pay tribute to Princess died during
the Royal Wedding in fact we're gonna
toss it over to lauren zima
who's got a hint about what what tribute
that actually is in the form of diamonds
we've heard some hints about what tiara
Megan Marco will wear on her big day
Lauren Megan Markel already has her
beautiful engagement ring from Prince
Harry but there's still plenty of wonder
about Markel's other sparkles including
people trying to figure out which
priceless tiara she'll wear on the big
royal wedding day so we are here at
House of Gerrard in London longtime
jeweler to the royal family we've got a
private appointment to talk tiaras and
just stare at some diamonds
house of dere art has been in London for
centuries they made none other than
Princess Diana's iconic engagement ring
Prince Charles kind of works with garage
to create you know it's a very classic
Greek but to create the classic ring
that he wanted so he picked the stone
the main stone which is sapphire they've
also made Tiaras for the royal family
including the Cambridge lovers not worn
by Diana and Kate Middleton but the
family has many crowns so which one will
Megan Don
it appears and I'm again I'm only
speculating a bit here that there's sort
of also a tradition of the Queen giving
this gift of a tiara of something from
her collection so so maybe that's a
really nice from the mother-in-law kind
of thing a lot of people have wondered
if we might see her where the Spencer
tiara which has not been worn since
Princess Diana's death well that
wouldn't be probably be up there when
the odds I would say but I'd say it's
probably a contender and I think people
would embrace that and be enthusiastic
about it and the story because you know
all these things are really about
stories stories that the pieces of
jewelry just collect they become sort of
icons of style which talk about Megan
say and she's worn she's wants some sort
of dainty but some more edgy pieces in
the past and let's see that carry on I
like to see that too actually but we'll
have to wait until Saturday to see what
tiara Megan does walk down the hall in
but of course there's already so much
speculation over who shall wear on the
big day if you're that and more we've
got our et senior style editor Marisa
Runyon hello
I think we've brought up the dress every
day it's such a secretive thing but you
have a couple of hints and ideas of who
she might decide to wear so the fashion
world is obviously obsessed with this as
mi and when Women's Wear Daily actually
has been tapping designers to design
some sketches if they could design a
dress for Megan Merkel what would it be
so we have we've seen some from Tommy
Hilfiger
which is amazing Antonio Morris and a
French designer Alexei Minh
and I saw this photo I'm sure you guys
all saw it of Megan Markos mother on her
way to London and she is holding garment
bag and it is a Burberry garment bag so
clue that could be a clue maybe
Burberry's dressing the entire family
it's Christopher Bailey's last season
after 17 years at Burberry so this could
be his swan song
he could be designing the royal wedding
gown what a swans I know exactly be
amazing I was wondering if she was gonna
go with an American designer cuz you
know she is American but I see her
wanting to pay tribute to the the
monarchy and of course the UK in general
so I can't wait to see what she's gonna
wear I hope it's as dramatic as I
imagined in my head you know long as it
has to be this is the only occasion for
a complete drama is a royal wedding all
eyes are on her side a magic show do you
think that she'll go edgy or trendy at
all with her luck you know she has more
leeway to do that because
directly she's not going to be Queen one
day theoretically so I think she'll have
to stick with tradition but there should
be and I'm hoping there'll be a little
modern touch of something a little more
fashion-forward from her you're not the
only one who feels that way in fact et
has spoken to a lot of designers leading
up to the Royal Wedding about what make
them aware here's what they think and
are predicting and hoping to see her
rock on the big day take a look I have a
feeling we'll see something you know a
little bit modern I don't think it's
gonna be a traditional and fonta kind of
old-school bridal gown but I have a
feeling whatever it is she's gonna look
remarkable I also would understand if
she chooses to work go British but would
it make me happy to see where an
American yes for a first-time bride you
can wear pure away but given the fact
that Megan is married for the second
time she can wear pearl but she can't
wear white it's once-in-a-lifetime the
whole world is watching you need to have
a statement you can't just go with a
little dress the whole world is watching
they want to see more they want to see
some bland
she will definitely kind of push the
envelope but I think she'll be
definitely respectful to the royal
family and you know to the UK in general
so I think she'll if nothing will be too
exposed
I think she might go a little more
form-fitted she'll still need the
grandness of something you know big
embellish sleeves or a big flounce or
something for the magnitude of the
Cathedral but I think she's going to go
a little you know sexy or not an obvious
way you know Mark Zunino also told us
that he thinks Megan will redefine what
it means to be a princess and I don't
think he's wrong there right now what do
you think about the white versus cream
debate there I kind of cringed when she
said wedding you know we all know she's
been married before I'm one for
tradition but it's shades of color she's
gonna wear white it's not like she was
gonna show up in a pink bridal gown and
took people who don't know it like for
myself I think it's still white like you
know Carol it looks like what right yeah
I can't tell the difference so of course
that's the predictions and and of what
Megan will wear on the big day for her
wedding gown
we also have a full Bridal makeup
tutorial up on et's Facebook and YouTube
channel part of spilling the royalty
they who gave us a tutorial on Megan's
Bridal makeup what they would like to
see her rock you know makeup wise for
the big day but you know what it's not
just her such as Megan who has to dress
up it's the guess if the bridesmaids
it's the party um you actually have the
scoop on like the rules of what to wear
- oh there's just like there's rules
when we go to a wedding based on the the
venue and the grandness of a ceremony
there's a lot of royal wedding rules
what's the first one the very first one
so for men on the wedding invitation
itself it says that men can wear and
have to wear either a uniform a morning
coat or lounge so I'll to find those for
you so the uniform very clear any
members of the royal family they attend
the wedding in their most formal uniform
and a morning coat so a morning coat is
what we see in the United States as men
wearing to a daytime wedding so it's the
coat with tails a waistcoat usually
striped trousers David Beckham actually
that's what he wore to Winky Will and
Kate's wedding so if you want to look up
photos and then a lounge a lounge so
there we go and a lounge is just a suit
okay it's just a very fancy way of
saying a suit right really oh yes so in
other words I would be denied at the
door if I showed up looking like this to
the world
I need my lounge you need to wear your
lounge I need my coattails noted for
Saturday don't worry I'm gonna cross
that thing from from afar i'ma do it I'm
gonna do it show up dressed
inappropriately I bet they wouldn't
allow you into the church yeah they have
security there that's just eyeing the
Wardrobe you thing I bet and I'm it must
be also a way to keep out people who
were invited
I mean I'm assuming you have to show
some sort of credentials to get into
that but I just imagine Anna Wintour
standing at the doors yes no yes exactly
I love it gentlemen what about the
ladies ladies so very very general rules
of being polite and conservative you're
in a church or in one of the most formal
events you'll probably ever attend so
women must cover their shoulders so any
dress that a lady chooses should err on
the side of being more conservative and
you'll see many women cover their
shoulders usually cover most of their
arms at least down to the elbow so I
think you know that's a pretty standard
rule when attending weddings in most
churches or temples or presence of
worship are there any rules about
hemline yes
so hemline should also be conservative
and possibly down to the knee and that's
not a hard and fast rule I don't think
it's written anywhere but if you look
around at what people wore to Will and
Kate's wedding you'll see everybody was
all the women were really dressed
conservatively and elegantly so no many
dresses no parties no bandaged and then
lastly obviously white and cream and any
color within that white vicinity is
solely reserved for the bridal party so
you may remember Pippa Middleton she
wore white to Will and Kate's wedding
but again she's a member of the bridal
party and that's a very old-fashioned
tradition that the bridal party would
also wear white all right as far as
accessories I mean the big one of course
is the oh no we mean the most important
thing this of this whole occasion
in fact we have a couple here I think
these are fascinating
yeah buddy laters okay the interesting
thing about these is technically this
would not be laughter away because oh
actually the way little small but most
of the time they would have a hat at the
base of it and then have that flourish
super cute we're getting in but you
might need to like make it a little bit
bigger apparently yeah okay there's a
couple rules and and Lauren seemed
actually interviewed that's right Milner
Louise Greene about this so a hat can't
be too large because you'll block
people's people to ceremony and it also
can't be too small it can't simply be a
headband with the feather on it right
I'm not sure I could pull it off y'all
not sure I could pull it off but you
know what When in Rome or in this case
the UK I love it that interview with
Louie screen was really fun in fact the
shout-out to Louie she made some hats
for Lauren for the trips you guys want
to see that segment that's also up on e
t--'s YouTube channel and Facebook page
as well but so fun well no matter what
it's gonna be such a regal affair and
people gonna be dressed to the nines I
can't wait to see everybody's fashions
what they pick you know who they do they
wear I mean I think that's what most
people are really looking forward to
yeah obviously everyone wants to see
Meghan's dress right in the parade of
hats I'm looking forward to a great
event I said it starts here folks it
starts here well Marissa thank you so
much for all that tea on the fashions
you guys we're three days away from the
Royal Wedding which means we have two
three more days of daily denne live
actually there's so much more to report
you guys so stick around tomorrow we're
gonna show you how to throw a regal
viewing party for the Royal Wedding oh
yeah you guys don't want to miss that to
make sure exactly exactly make sure you
subscribe to et's youtube channel and
following us here on Facebook and thank
you guys so much for watching we'll see
you here tomorrow bye bye
[Music]